hey I was going sisters welcome to the
most loved show in America thyroid stuff
online and we have a guest who's the
honor to be on the show today PJ he did
a pillow pillow face guys everyone
remember pillow face guy beep I remember
pillow face guy from my childhood I
remember all the comics all the TV shows
especially the anime this is really good
I was very good what are we doing
why weird stuff Berlin oh cool so we're
not doing some impossible game like
guess the celebrity based on the far
we're just doing something nice and
simple I know we've done a lot of
competitions PJ I'm out with bud head of
the line oh yeah I know you lost a lot
don't worry but don't worry PJ this time
it's not a competition
okay may be all about having fun is it
you're just scared so you don't want it
to be a competition okay
natural man let's go we'll do s my time
to shine okay okay are you ready for the
item number one hell yeah hit me I don't
think you're ready for item number one
there's two io one each which one do you
want which I'll take the box I think you
want this one excellent
I'll take the box if you put what's in
the box what's in the box I wonder what
do not [ __ ] you box okay sponsored by
Amazon so that's not the right one oh
great let's call that ha ha ha
if you think I'm gonna pawn like a
sailor outfit little girl Sailor Moon
outfit yeah no I'm not put on the damn
Sailor Moon outfit oh wow it looks so
good wow this is amazing what is it
Felix
it is animate scored right where you
forgot the skirt I forgot the skirt I
mean there's no chance that if this
doesn't fit how okay whatever
okay nice skirt Hayashi the gut does fit
actually can fit how does the scuff man
I so weird that I that my outfit mmm
we're I can't find it and just misplaced
it that's really strange
huh here's me vocalist wears them yeah
usually that would happen Tyler you look
good
thank you you look freaking as you can
see this is the 2017
Sailor Moon anime leather look hey Jana
so what this is I thought you said this
video is five weird things online this
is a perfectly normal that's that then
if you're wearing like that at Zepp
another government yeah what's next we
listen oh I don't think you're ready for
next one I'm ready for next I mean if
this is off your Amazon I know what Jack
put on that list next Adam what's next
hey I didn't know you had a new products
feel like there's new merch or something
let me see fufu deployment oh yeah no I
see what you mean that's funny that's
real funny cuz it's [ __ ] yeah daddy okay
there we go
who had everybody okay so if you already
have an outfit on I think you should put
it on as well I've already got enough
about now I think feels you need to I
think that people want to see it always
a game it's a game okay let's see how
many points you can get PG I get to
throw [ __ ] at you I'm this is on behalf
of all the bros this is for you matter
of the sister is all for you guys the
status resists to better come on three
point three Jake well chase it ah hold
on you will come wait oh no need for my
Ramos hinder you
ah your turn now okay
ready for this PJ rip me damn it
miss yeah hey yes you hit the wall
how many points on every one red boy
next Adam come on what is this a paper
girl
it just said like don't eat Tony oh okay
well what is I don't live like fish eggs
yeah what's it gonna I'm interested I
didn't what this is going to shoot I'm
very intrigued ah I missed everything
okay that's what can just walking bodies
make is like all right this is why we
need Michael to clean oh my god
come clean out back from Romania okay I
didn't scared cuz like I don't know the
power either be suspicious
no baby no what yeah I'm ready I'm ready
ah love it Oh shouldn't you make sure it
just shoot that little gooey ball I was
expecting like waves of vapor right
right next items I am do you have you
ever grown up ooom um no I'm aware time
to grow up Oh everybody what what this
is what sort of a [ __ ] things get spill
it oh so you mine I'm PJ all right this
takes 72 hours uni yes one of those grow
your own friends have you run our
friends Felix that you now need to grow
your own shitty friend it's time to grow
the poopy hey okay how does it feel I
was it's like a rubbery kind of texture
right I know it's kind of okay well it
the way they showed it was they used to
put in
really but then I can't use the toilet
first Trinity yeah
what who thought this would be a good
idea next item that really is a [ __ ]
item Felix
what is this this looks amazing
I know have you ever played hot potato
I'll for [ __ ] sake is just going to
know that 29 I'm sure II know is this
gonna let your Cheetos
nah oh here we go okay okay what we just
got happy but we're just going to throw
it beaching ji said you changes barely
touch it so that's the whole point of
hot potato if it's a hot potato
I don't want to touch it you know well
segment your game mattress I don't think
it I'm just presenting it oh yeah did
you get here I guess that's what you
need to do you to shake it well the
great item PJ that was really fun yeah
we're going after than one thing Aven oh
that's what this was all about you
brought me over it just to show your
weakness we yeah Electric who would have
[ __ ] saw are you ready for item
number how's the fit Isis I'm gonna
number five and a half five okay five
Ivan all right hit your other weakness
fire do you like to drink
PJ um occasionally water empty this is
probably the most hilarious thing of
everything okay in my life okay yeah
feet speeds cross oh wow okay so how
does this house is amazing adventure one
box it I'll get Kelly a drink
help he is holding me against my will
What did he say to you don't lie to me
he's speaking like let's see what we got
we got quite a variety here we have oh
they're double scientist as well uh
that's a con man these are grapes why
would you want these how do they work
you poke the straw through it oh that's
not yelling hmm all right okay all right
I was skeptical but that's kind of funny
that's funny right
hmm oh wow
PJ with that outfit in that AK Lexus man
okay next item
yeah just wait until you see their face
man oh sorry I'll show y'all sorry Felix
just a mighty fine party we got one more
ayat to Moorabbin okay all right well we
got oh wow a child's toy yeah is that
what the channels come to we going back
to war with his name what was the little
boy the reviewed stuff Brian rivalry
knows what else comes to feel like toy
real girl
hey what's kind of you look like you
could use a nope no swag excuse me
you look like you could use a little bit
of a yeah cuz I'm the hairier one
attitude what is this what happened to
the whack-a-mole toy don't worry about
it I was so excited to play
hang on give me just the Mouse King it
was but you oh Jesus
you knocked the batteries out gee the
how is this for kids Felix has bought
this with his own money
and as we all know he is low on money we
are going to get some enjoyment out next
Adam
so the nose wax ah all right what what
makes you think that this would be weird
remove sealed blows hair regrow what how
what are we going to do what are we
going to do here what do you think is
going to happen now you know the ten
says it's painless okay so you do the
nostrils with this one yeah no we are
far from Ryan's toy reviews here this is
the best part of their yeah seriously
throw the rest of throw the rest away
they follow that pretty good now I look
like a schoolgirl the vapor gun was the
only one where I sort of thought this
could have potential and then let me
down everything else just let me down
immediately so what kind of notes max
kit comes with a mess there hell yeah
what was even the point of this is why I
want to know she's played an impossible
join us next time for fair we stuff on
land the most loved show in America
Helen P just coming on as a guest the
rest of the world hates the show only
America
oh sorry leave a like everybody if you
enjoyed check out PJ and remember to
smile